[Musique]
il est enfin là le feu d'artifice
organisé par elancourt maurepas et la
verrière initialement prévu le 13
juillet c'est finalement le 28 août qui
les tirait à la coulée verte de la
commanderie je trouve c'est une bonne
idée moi ça fait ça fait plaisir de voir
un feu d'artifice comme au mois d'août
même pas un autre c'est toujours très
agréable à ce beau spectacle est aussi
c'est tout je suis assez fan des feux
d'artifice c'était la première fois que
je venais le voir et franchement je
trouve ça très bien moins de trois
minutes mine derrière c'est vraiment pas
mal et c'était très beau très joli site
et wright must est vraiment sympathique
j'ai bien aimé à quelques minutes du
spectacle le 13 juillet dernier les
maires avaient pris la décision de
reporter le feu d'artifice à cause de la
météo un mal pour un bien au vu du
nombre important de spectateurs présents
à la fin des vacances c'est une bonne
nouvelle parce que vous savez quand on
le fait aussi le 13 juillet la veille de
la fête nationale beaucoup de nos
habitants sont aussi en vacances et là
aussi c'est l'occasion d'inviter aussi
d'autres habitants qui n'ont pas
l'habitude de venir et donc voilà
c'était aussi une fierté pour pour nous
en tant qu'élu de pouvoir faire
bénéficier le plus grand nombre ce feu
d'artifice marque aussi la première
collaboration pour un tel événement
entre les trois communes elancourt
maurepas et la verrière un projet commun
réussi qui donne des idées pour l'avenir
on est dans un état d'esprit
intercommunal de plus en plus les villes
sont amenés à travailler ensemble et
donc c'est important pour la ville de la
verrière de renouer avec ses partenaires
ça permet de diminuer les coûts et ça
permet d'avoir un spectacle de très
grande qualité pour les familles ont
réfléchi sur un spectacle pour les
communes de saint quentin pour quelque
chose mais de forts liens encore plus
forts ce soir c'est jane première étape
mais voilà on travaille sur une étape
bien sûr suivante le coût du feu
d'artifice entre 30000 à 40000 euros un
beau spectacle pour conclure l'été en
beauté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]